okay I just blew it up in there you
might wanna wait oh yeah cool Anki and
drive me to the airport tomorrow at 5:00
yeah whatever
cool yo there's some beer in the fridge
want some cool hey I'm gonna have a girl
over later as it cool B's the TV sure
cool hey I mow the lawn because I knew
you're too busy to Thanks no where's it
took down all the Christmas stuff when
you were gone sweet cool hey I like your
glasses
thanks I like your shirt Thanks hey did
you eat my burrito yeah thanks for being
honest with me I got you back cool I
haven't started the show yet I was
waiting for you oh cool we can start now
cool how's your day fine yours was
whatever cool did you get the same
sunglasses that I already own yeah is
that cool it's fine can I borrow your
new jacket for my date son cool hey I
just went to tickets for the Super Bowl
on the radio do you want to go with me
hell yeah cool hey are you busy right
now
no cool uh I just kind of wanted to get
something off my chest
what's what I just blew up the bathroom
so I wouldn't go in there for another
like 25 minutes it's bad
Thanks cool